[Music]
now that was real education
the schoolhouse rock but it is
a week of technological disruption
i don't know if you guys have been
following this at all but i've been
following it a little bit obsessively
today in between doing work and i have
uh i did quite enjoy the narrative so
everyone's going
everyone's going aha we don't have a
free market it's designed for the
wealthy
that seems to be the that seems to be
the takeaway if there's a good takeaway
it's that it's they're very clearly
saying we cannot let the pigs
run the farm yeah and then it's funny to
see um
some like right wingers more populist
right-wingers agreeing with like
left-wingers there's that nice exchange
between aoc
and ted cruz right i think ted cruz like
had a little
like pointing finger emoji down to aoc's
uh like tweet and was just like i
fully agree and then she retweeted and
being like well you kind of incited
people to try to have me killed so like
i like to work with
republicans but you're a douche
effectively
that was a brief glimpse of a better
world
yeah well in terms of an on on topic
segway that we can make here it's uh
very much a disruption
of an institution an almost sacred
institution by means of uh new
technology
which is something that i'm sure our
discussion will at least
uh bring up today because in addition to
wall street finance capital uh the
university is one of the few
definitely sacred sacred uh or or
at least having a sacred aura of an
institution
that uh still remains with us yeah i
guess it's c i mean
i don't really like that word sacred but
fine
that was the most petulant i think i've
ever heard you say i don't like that
word safe
but fine how about
imbued with fantasy oh yeah well yeah of
course of course a sublime object
yeah the transcendental object so our
episode is entitled do not go to grad
school
i don't know if all of us are going to
say that no i'm i'm probably going to no
nope you can make a case you can make a
case for it but i think this podcast
should be called
should you go to grad school question
mark
i think of the same thing i was like i
don't know if i can fully get behind
that message
but i mean you got to go for the
assertions in the title first of all and
university is a scam you have to admit
so pills give us your case and then we
can have some rebuttals
oh is it gonna is it gonna be three
against one no i don't know i don't know
i think it'll be like two against one
maybe two and a half
i mean for complexity's sake like if
like undergrad did come up to me and say
like should i go get a master's degree
should i go to grad school
like i would have to ask a series of
questions before i could answer that
like i wouldn't
i wouldn't just be like yes you should
or no you shouldn't like i would have to
interrogate them a little bit be like
well like what are your interests what
did you do
i don't even know what kind of questions
i would ask because
yeah i did it but does my experience
generalize
that's exactly my thought right i would
i think it's really individuated and
we'll probably talk about it so i won't
rant about too much
but i would have to ask questions i'd
have to figure out who this person was
what their ambitions were what their
interests happened to be
i don't want to be after that that i
would say yay or nay
for now it's don't do it but maybe by
the end it'll be do it
well the reason that i bring this up is
it's one of the most frequent comments i
get when i'm on
online i guess or or questions should i
i'm thinking about it uh what's your
take
so here's my take and i'm gonna be
taking a hard line
and uh you guys can maybe soften me up
or we'll bring this somewhere near the
middle i'm excited
for this hot hot spicy take deuces
horseshoe theory already has his degree
by the way
not in the midst of one yeah has his phd
and is just like don't don't do it guys
which is i guess
a good position of authority to have
that take potentially to have done it
yeah better to have that and say it yes
university is wonderful but don't do it
but yeah it would be
it would be way more suspicious it would
be way more suspicious if you like had
started a phd and then dropped out and
then you were telling people like don't
go but like the fact that you finished
it definitely does add credibility so
yeah
i'm a year one phd and this is all
[ __ ] i tell you
all right well i'm gonna take the line
that not only is university a scam
i i think we're talking post undergrad
because scam sends religion
in general though i think that you have
to understand this as a transaction
because it costs money and you're
exploited
so that you can do this performative
thing and get your honorific after your
name
and i think it's not yet disrupted what
i'm arguing for is that it should be
disrupted can be disrupted
just like the uh sacred institution of
wall street is
is reactively trying to clamp down on
the disruption that's occurring
this week but also
universities are corrupt bureaucracies
for 100 millionaires or billionaires to
put their names on buildings
yeah for construction contracts from the
cousins of
of board members and they exist to
launder these contracts and then
to uh get endowment money that they can
stick into
halliburton and get big bonuses for
their
their board and ceos which i think is a
better
term for the people who run these
institutions than uh president
so that's my initial case it's a it's a
corrupt way to uh
invest your time and your debt so
because
so because there are capital interests
behind some universities you're saying
it's a scam
what do you mean some universities well
i mean i think it's to lesser and
greater degrees right like i think the
american system is a particularly
um egregious example of that but like
europe and canada like there's much less
i mean
there is a lot of that but like the but
the degree of it like i mean the
billions of dollars we're talking about
i'll get less and less the more public
your post-secondary education system is
i was totally gonna bring that up i'm
gonna actually post this on our
even though it's a public episode i want
to put it on our patreon because that's
where we get
like accurate feedback so i do want to
know
if this applies also to our european
indian australian listeners
i assume to like more greater or fewer
degrees but if
at least a few european countries
undergrad and parts of post-grad are
virtually free so i think that would uh
kind of
dilute my argument a little bit if that
were the case so this is
basically applying to our context and
even more so to the
americans especially america i mean i
mean university is still relatively
affordable to a canadian like like if
you want to get a degree it's i mean
comparatively speaking
but yeah i mean you're right like the
elite ivy league schools in america i
mean i remember one time having a
professor
telling me you know harvard is really a
multi-billion dollar organization with a
little side hustle
of educating students right yeah i mean
most people i know who graduated from
there uh either or from one of those
kind of institutions either
came from a huge amount of money uh
where i wasn't really an object or they
graduated with a quarter million 300 000
in debt which is not really viable for
many
since in order to get into that kind of
debt you also need people who are kind
of loan you that kind of money which
means that
it's your [ __ ] out of luck in most cases
right the sort of traditional
western wisdom about this is that
america
is like fully capitalist and their
tuition is
out of control canada is sort of in the
middle
we have tuition i mean i think like some
of the eastern provinces are getting rid
of it but mostly
we have like six thousand dollars a year
tuition or something and then and then
europe
is like minus england europe is like
fully socialist and they will just
sponsor
it you have state-sponsored education
there basically yeah
in quebec you if you're a quebec
resident i think you can get tuition at
like mcgill or whatever university there
for like under two thousand dollars a
year it's pretty cheap
and we should also stipulate at the
beginning uh we are talking about
probably just humanities phds i was
looking up stats
and i like all the stats are lumped in
with each other but
we don't know anything about basically
stem doctorates whether they're worth it
or not i'm sure they're probably more
worth it than
arts or humanities degrees or social
sciences as well
so i think that's kind of uh what the
thrust of our discussion is at but
there's not stats really on just
humanities phd specifically so we're
talking about tuition fees but
most of that applies to uh undergrads
well my my my loans would say otherwise
but like on top of tuition you have cost
of living which is extremely high
here in toronto so that's true i mean
when you factor everything else in
yeah it's really expensive if i had 100
grand 10 years ago then i could have
done all this
and come out with zero but i didn't so
that we don't have to
go around and like divulge our our
financial situation publicly
i think we can just stick with the
average because i checked this up today
the average
for a phd graduate
of debt in canada at least is 40k
yeah sounds about right and that's
that's a four-year undergraduate degree
and then grad school will add another
six years on top of that
that's just tuition right uh actually
going to the school paying for your cost
of living et cetera
one of the things that i think it's
worth noting about is that if you want
to be an effective
grad student uh you're going to need to
be armed with quite a bit more money
because people will tell you that if you
want to be an effective grad student
that also means conferencing which is
going to mean you're going to spend at
least a few thousand dollars a year
traveling to god knows what part of the
united states
for you know the big conference for your
discipline and so on uh you're also
going to need to have
the time to spend on writing papers
buying expensive books joining expensive
associations yeah then you have to join
the association that's putting on the
conference just to present at the
conference
so it's a scam it's a pyramid scheme i
don't think it's a scam
i'm just saying i'll get into this when
i make my more general point right that
if you want to be an effective grad
student you should need to be aware that
like anything else in life the costs on
the sheet of paper that you'll be
presented with
are just the surface costs to do it
properly or to do it effectively
you're gonna need to throw a lot more
money at it to get all you will out of
it
could we also be a little bit clearer
here on on when we say tuition like
you're absolutely right cost of living
but
i will say like right off the bat like
if you get
into a phd program that doesn't offer
you funding then you absolutely should
not do it
oh like there's no [ __ ] question
about that we're all agreed
do not go to grad school so like this
episode went quicker than i thought but
i think but
i'm sure a lot of our listeners don't
have uh don't necessarily know how phd
programs work so like i feel like we
should also be clear about
like what what we're talking about here
so at the undergraduate level unless you
have
like crazy grades in high school like
and even if you get a really good
scholarship at the undergraduate level
you're maybe gonna get like a couple
hundred maybe a couple thousand dollars
off of your tuition a year at least in
canada i don't know how it works in the
states i mean
there's to row or play football or
something yeah yeah
scholarship yeah exactly but like at the
phd level or
you know most programs have a like a
minimum funding package of i don't know
like
if it's got to be like at least i don't
know 18 000 a year which is obviously
not
very much like that's the minimum but my
point is like
let's not talk about it as if uh as if
as if you're paying 100 tuition for the
purpose actually
for the purpose of this discussion we'll
say is it worth it
40k in debt when you finish because
that's the average i'm gonna add two
qualifications right uh
i think that you should go to grad
school um
if you can get funding and if you're
really passionate about the material
those are the optimal conditions right
because if you can get a substantial
amount of funding and you're passionate
about material there are worse ways
to spend five six years in your 20s
let's just put it that way right if you
can't get funding
and you find yourself in the kind of
situation that pills is talking about
where you're likely going to take on 40
grand in debt that's a different kind of
question
right i think that you should do it in
that circumstance
if you're really passionate about the
material yes but also if you think
you're going to be able to find some way
to monetize that degree
in the future right because you'll get a
job or because you'll move into a field
where they're looking for researchers
or because you think that you're being
able to get a scholarship in the future
uh if you don't think you can get
monetized that's a much bigger
if you don't think you'll be able to
monetize it uh it's a much bigger
question
right because then you're essentially
assuming a lot of debt uh to pursue a
hobby
and i think you should think seriously
about whether or not that's a
wise life choice to make see this is why
i'm of like a split mind on this i've
got a bit of the schizo split going on
because
because of course i enjoyed my
experience
at grad school but also i think
like this whole like that's the one side
and the other side is
like the neo-liberalization of
universities that's been going on since
the 1980s
has definitely impacted the quality
of education that you get and the
quality
of our universities in general so
i think if the only thing standing in
your way
is money but otherwise you'd like to go
and if you can't afford to what we
should be doing is lobbying our
government to
make education
something for free for everybody right
is education a right
as the americans believe then why do you
have to pay so much
for it it's the same thing with health
care why do you have to pay for it out
the nose
if it's also like a basic human
requirement
is to be educated obviously not up to
the point of
grad school level education not everyone
needs that but then
from another perspective in order to be
competitive on the job market you can't
just have
an undergraduate degree anymore that's
crazy going into the
this decade now humanity is at least
well if you have just an
undergraduate degree in anything like
first of all i would say if you want to
be competitive okay take the extra year
or two and get a freaking master's
degree because why not
and then if you really love your [ __ ]
then go on to do another four-year phd
and if you're in a classic science
program you'll probably
work with a professor and be able to
work with them further into a post-doc
and then something may materialize for
you job-wise down the road
yes the humanities is a very different
story from that though
so let's let's keep our story to the
humanities because that's what we have
our experience with um but the the
disruption
argument to this is that
anything you learn or anything that we
learned
like we couldn't do this ten years ago
where you could just download books yeah
or maybe you could i didn't know about
it
now now it's like easier than ever yeah
you can have access to all the same
material that you are reading
the only thing that you're missing from
a lot of parts
of finding the stuff online trying to
read it yourself trying to figure it out
on yourself the only thing you're
missing is that i can see you can
correct me but
deadlines so at that point you're paying
for a babysitter
or the thing that actually matters is
personal relationships
and i think that uh with a lot of the
theory stuff that i'm seeing online
theorists coming out
online that's the thing that i think is
kind of changing that you can
form relationships in community
about kind of the thinkers that you like
and the things that you want to study
so i want to put that out there as a
disruption that i think will take
a chunk out of the
the benefits of grad school and seminars
which is exactly that
personal relationship that can
be reproduced maybe not as well but it
can be reproduced without 40k
debt actually that was going to bring me
up to the point that i wanted to make
because
one of the things that i think is often
not talked about when it comes to should
you go to grad school
is personalities there's usually a kind
of reductive materialism to it right how
much money is it going to cost what are
you going to get and so on
not what the kind of interpersonal
experiences you're going to get are
and this is kind of going to be said in
jess but one of the things that you
should consider is that
graduate school tends to attract certain
kinds of personalities
uh and you're likely to meet one of the
five following people there
and i would say if you think that you
can slot yourself in with one of these
five people
then that could actually be an incentive
to you because it means that there'll be
a group that you can hang out with and
you'll probably have a good time with
right
you know a you'll meet the person who's
basically loved undergrad because of the
parties the drinking
uh you know the drugs all the kind of
stuff wants the party to keep on going
well into their 20s and possibly their
30s and if you think you're that kind of
person then grad school will definitely
have a lot to offer you
right the next kind of person you'll
meet that's a lot less pleasant
is the ultra snob and interestingly
enough these exist on the left and the
right
uh you know you'll meet the marxist
ultra snobs and they'll talk about how
they're fundamentally different than the
straussians what actually
if you were to get them into a room and
they didn't know each other's political
ideology
it would basically be the same white
dude talking about how nobody reads the
right books anymore
they're pretty annoying but if you
happen to think of yourself as a snob
that's where you want to go right then
you get like the ultra leftist who's
kind of the inverse of the snob
who basically sees the point of theory
as being some kind of activism
or academia right and
he or she will always be more vegan more
socialist more feminist
more woke than everybody else and
in a beautiful world they'll be a very
nice person
in a frustrating world they'll be
policing everyone's conversation
and if you think you're that kind of
person definitely go there
[Laughter]
please don't please don't they're the
ones who
give you [ __ ] for not being outside
during a labor action
exactly then there's a fourth kind of
person who's very
rare but sometimes you'll meet them and
it's like the genuine scholar and you'll
meet them
they're really nice people they're super
passionate about their work
they'll love to [ __ ] talk to you
about it uh and the only thing that's
annoying about them
is the fact that if you want to sit down
and have a beer with them you're going
to have to [ __ ] talk about the lose
right at the very beginning like you got
to broach their interest you got to have
that conversation
and once you can get past that they're
usually pretty good guys or women
and if you spend some time with them
they're really helpful if you want to
know anything about that topic or rawls
how about we throw rawls in there so i'm
not
yeah sure and then there's the last
person rolls-games are always nice
people
they are yeah i've never met a mean
rally but plenty of like mean marks of
plenty means straussians never mean also
then the last person that you'll meet
sometimes is what i like to call the
burnout
and the burnout is usually what happens
when the partier hits like 35
to like 40. still is trying to keep it
going but let's just be honest it's not
working anymore
and basically they're just like kind of
parasite in the institution
living off of ta ships ra ships and
whatever free food they give away
and usually blaming the institution for
why they're not graduating but let's be
honest
uh they don't know what they would do
with their life if they happen to leave
so they'll just be there forever
don't wind up like that person they'll
be there they're usually harmless
and they can sometimes be funny because
they'll tell you jokes about how things
were back in the old days
right so if you think you're one of
these five people or you can get along
with one of these five people
you should go to grad school because
you'll have a good time if any of these
people sounds too threatening or too
frustrating
you should think twice that's my word
that's interesting i really appreciate
the classifications and your preparation
for this the true scholar i don't know
if you guys want to add one but i
definitely want to add
the careerist oh yes oh yeah the career
the sixth is the careerist they are the
person that
you can't even tell really what their
research is
in whether or not they're actually
interested in it it's all
conferencing publishing following their
supervisor around
meeting up with the people who are
giving out course assignments
and strategic at all times strategic at
all times but they
actually tend to do pretty well they do
they do they
i would say i kind of want to add to
this is something i've said in the past
i think maybe even on a really early
episode of the podcast just
that i think it's important to know what
it is and i think like
i think the careerist does tend to do
well but the problem with the careerist
i think like going into grad school
especially like a theory phd
being like i'm gonna go so that i can
get a job as a professor i would say
don't go
if that's like you're if like if that's
your objective going into it that you're
like okay i'm gonna do this and i'm
gonna be a professor for sure
um i think to some extent like you have
to
like you you can go in you just have to
go in with some
self reflexivity about yourself and the
current market
yeah so like that can't be your only
reason like that can be your hope that's
certainly my hope i mean that's matt's
hope
i'm i'm sure you know and like to have a
tenure-track job i mean
um but i think that if you go in being
like i'm gonna do this because i'm gonna
get a job you're kind of
misunderstanding the job market and like
what it actually entails and what's
necessary
i think you have to go in both with the
idea that
i'm doing this because i love it because
i don't want to be working in a cubicle
in some job and i would rather and if
you if you are strategic enough about
like getting scholarships and going to a
university that gives you a generous
funding package
it's difficult it's not easy but you can
live and not have debt that's possible
um you can and if you're if you like
manage to get scholarships right you can
uh there are ways of doing it and
getting a living wage
and if you can manage to do that and you
don't have this expectation
that you're gonna get a job right after
and you're kind of realistic and you can
hedge a little bit
it can be an amazing experience and i
would strongly recommend it in those
circumstances
because i certainly don't want to live
in like live in a cubicle working in
some office and like that's kind of the
choice yeah
i agree part-time job is a real good
idea
that's what i did um i just wanna also
because you mentioned it i looked up
these stats
as well in 2015
of graduated phds so not beginning but
graduated phds
one in five i think this is canada
scan one in five eventually got
tenure track it didn't say when we know
we know a bunch of people that are like
in their mid-40s that are still gunning
for tenure track
do not have it so one in five if so if
that's your goal
you have a 20 chance in 2015
but since 2015 every single year the
number of
phd graduates has gone up in both the
united states and canada
and the amount of jobs has stayed the
same or gone down
so if it was one in five five years ago
it's even lower now
and it's gonna keep getting lower so if
you're thinking about starting now
uh that's the reality of the situation
yeah for sure i mean there's some
variance there for sure and like
depending on
on where you go and what you focus on
like a quick example i mean this isn't
the theory job market but
i'm situated in a political science
department doing political theory
but it's interesting because my
political science colleagues in my
department
there's one specialization at the
university of toronto where
almost everyone gets a job if they
specialize in that
and that is canadian politics so if you
want to study canadian politics
you'll get a job uh pretty much right
away
which is interesting um but yeah i mean
uh like
so i also kind of want to say that for
me like
going to grad school like we were
talking earlier i mean pills brought up
the point you know what is the the
disruptive point about like all these
things are available online
i kind of want to make an impassioned
like uh
you know just i don't know if a plea or
an impassioned argument necessarily but
just that i think there's something
really fundamentally different and
special about the seminar room but the
experience in the seminar room i don't
really think that that can be reproduced
online
the new sublime object i mean
i'm just speaking from my own personal
experience like there's something
there's an inner subjective i mean
there's a phenomenology that's different
about being in in the room with people
talking having a professor that's
conducting the discussion
in like a reciprocal and dialogical
fashion that is
you know a special experience that i
remember you know
going into it and and and like having
those experiences doesn't happen all the
time where you're like okay like this is
why i'm here this these these are the
kinds of experiences
to talk about theory so that's one thing
the seminar room and then obviously like
the experience of going
to the bar after seminar with your
friends to talk about theory more i mean
those are some some of the best memories
the other thing i would say too is that
that's also fundamentally different from
the
i mean pills you touched on it when you
said deadlines
i think it's a little more than
deadlines i think it's that's true
but it's also having someone who's going
to read your work and give you feedback
um that you're that like is different
like yes you can read theory you can
watch
videos about theory and like you you can
get a lot out of it but i will just say
for myself that i i
like that feeling you get after you
write a paper and you get feedback on it
like that is a different level of
learning
than just like watching or reading a
video like i feel like you don't really
learn it similar to like
the experience you get from having to
teach something having to write about
something and
use it in like your own creative
endeavor to make an argument
is fundamentally different than just
reading the arguments and being like oh
this is interesting like writing it
putting to work
can't really replace that that i agree
with
so we have to replicate that well how
about we add a patreon tier
where you get to write papers for no
credit we'll grade them
and we'll grade them you know what
that's not i would be totally open
seminar tier kills you yeah wait really
if you want to if you want to start a a
patreon tier where people submit their
work and like we have to like grade it
and give feedback i would definitely be
open to being part of that well hey look
prager you [ __ ] created a fake
university why can't we we are better
qualified to create a [ __ ] fake
university in social science or
humanities than prageru is
the plastic phil's seminary the
classical seminary yeah
no i didn't agree with uh victor though
i think that
there are a lot of things about grad
school that simply can't be emulated
online yet
and that's not a dis at uh you know
online forums
um this will never be replicated i don't
think
you need the inner subject of the
phenomenology being in the presence of
other bodies can't be replaced
yeah but what if we had philosophy
retreats
yeah philosophy camp anyway sorry i cut
you off there that sounds like the most
dorky thing i could imagine but it would
be fun you gotta admit
i think the most important thing about
this though is genuinely getting
professional feedback
and this is something that i find you
don't see
as consistently in a lot of these online
forums where there's a little bit more
of a kind of an arcade anything goes
type mentality
and that's fine there's a nice kind of
democratic quality to that but when it
comes
to producing high tier
uh reflective work there is something
said
to be said for somebody who's got a lot
of experience who's been in the field
for a long time who knows it really well
and who's going to take your work and
basically tell you like this is crap you
don't know what you're thinking about
you have a lot to learn so here's what
you got to do
and i remember i had to go through this
during my undergraduate degree and
through grad school right a lot of
people would say like you're just wrong
about this you don't know what you're
talking about and that really hurts and
it's really frustrating
but then you fail and you fail again and
you fail better and then eventually at
some point
you're the guy who sits there and you
have a few things of interest to say
right and i'm not sure that you can
create that same kind of environment
in an online setting because quite
frankly if somebody on twitter or on a
forum said your work is crap
i'd probably just tell them well you can
go [ __ ] yourself right yeah yeah well
what the [ __ ] do you think you know
right who are you to tell me that
god i agree with that so so strongly
like i think you know to use kind of
you know almost al in bloom like lofty
language about academia and
uh even though i'm opposed to him you
know i do think that there's something
important about the development of an
intellectual or
an intellectual soul that requires
being brought pushed down to size by
someone who knows better
and having some intellectual humility
and i think that the problem with online
forums and online form like
they read it and then they think they
know it but where is the development for
intellectual humility
in fact i would say online there's very
little intellectual humility
i'll take your side for just this one
this one statement at least or one point
i'll take your i'll take your side for
this one point and that's that
especially
in interdisciplinary courses if you can
get them
like i took courses in in in film
and in history and in religion and
that to me is invaluable because even
though
they're your peers they're actually
experts in something
and you know they're like semi experts
whereas you're not
and if you if you go find like a delize
reading group
or something then you just know by
default everyone there's going to like
deliz so you wouldn't even not just push
back from
other from professors but push back from
people
who you fundamentally disagree with
and that's an environment that i've only
encountered so far in
the university because online forums are
up to you
you choose where to go and what to
consume however
i however i don't think that that could
not be replicated online
also i'll i'll just give you an example
and
maybe this will entice eric to join our
side right um
think about like all the crappy books uh
that are written by like pop
intellectuals about
social justice activism post-modern
theory you name it right
uh i hate to say it because i've read a
ton of these right but
most of the ones that are like truly god
awful like just
[ __ ] deserve to be on like the manure
pile are written by people who
didn't have like a strong academic
background and it you can tell
because all they're used to doing is
like catering to their audience
right they know that the people who read
this are primarily going to be converted
to their side already so they don't have
to make any kind of effort
to actually try to convince somebody to
believe something
that they didn't believe already right
that's very different than the handful
of books i've read in this
subgenre that are actually good almost
all of which are written by academics
and you can see it right people like
alan sokol because they treat the
material like an academic they say
i've gone through to lose his paper and
i've gone through beaujora's paper and
i've gone through this
here are the citations and this is why i
think they're wrong
and you might sit there and think well i
still disagree with the interpretation
or they're not being particularly
charitable
but it's leagues apart then all the crap
that you sometimes get from like uh
these kind of pop intellectuals who
write books on their subject matter
and i've seen similar patterns emerge
everywhere else and that's not to say
that
you need a degree to write a good book
on an
intellectual summer matter and i could
point to other examples where people
have written good books
uh who don't have like a formal
education but it definitely helps
right particularly if you're going to be
writing about political material where
the temptation can always just be to
cater to
like a very partisan audience that'll
swallow anything that
regurgitates uh what they happen to
believe already
right yeah eric what are you thinking of
well this is a topic i am very
conflicted about
so i don't i don't have a rough and
ready opinion about the whole thing
i mean yes i think i think uh
undergrad and graduate education is
pretty much essential to modern society
like we we can't get by without it
but on the other hand like if you're a
dedicated auto did act
you can teach yourself this stuff like
good on you you don't need to do it you
could become an independent scholar you
can prove yourself in other ways but
i mean let's face it like most people
aren't that most people can't do it on
their own
like i i sign up for classes in the gym
because i can't [ __ ] work out myself
because i find it boring i have no
motivation i need to go
somewhere and have someone tell me what
to do
even if you look perfect the way you are
oh well thank you
thank you i appreciate that even if i
know
what to do even even if i know what
exactly what to do i won't do it because
i don't have the motivation i can't do
it myself
i need the classroom i need the
structure i need
just to be somewhere other than my house
or in a cafe because it's also
distracting
like feedback helps yeah like any kind
of constructive criticism is great
if you treat it in the right way and
actually go back and read it
yeah but i mean also i i don't i don't
necessarily miss
the seminars or this like like 90
of the people at university i didn't
care for
i didn't i didn't enjoy them i met a few
people and that was great but like most
of
most people i'm like [ __ ] these people i
don't give a [ __ ] about them
they're fine people but i don't want to
know them i think that we in terms of
technological disruption
because so much of this stuff is now
available that wasn't available even
10 years ago or or even like 50 years
ago when the universities owned
all the books pretty much and it was
difficult to find even what you could
should read if you wanted to i think
i can hypothesize that we can foresee
there
being a generation of non-credentialed
theorists and they're probably 20 right
now
and most of them won't do it but you
gotta assume that there's going to be
that auto die that out there
who really can get it most people who
think they're an auto diet act are not
auto didact's though yeah
this is for the 20 year olds you're
probably not as smart as you think you
are
but there's probably a 20 year old out
there who is actually as smart as
never forget that 20 year olds i spend a
lot of time on twitter and generally
speaking anybody who has a hashtag
that goes something like self-taught
philosopher
inevitably you start watching the videos
and it's basically like academia is a
ponzi scheme
academics don't know what they're
talking about academics you know don't
have real ideas because they're too
afraid of the system
my iq is 180. natural selection
indicates that you know i'm on the top
of the pecking order la hashtag you know
jordan peterson hashtag iran
and then you actually read their stuff
and it's just like a bunch of malarkey
i'm not saying that the person
knows that they're going to be that i'm
just saying that they're probably
out there people nose to the grindstone
on their own able to teach themselves
able to build themselves a structure and
discipline and
all that stuff i think they're out there
and they're not going to have a phd
in 20 years i'm sure that'll happen yeah
it's worth noting that like academic
philosophy just used one example right
uh
only really emerged starting in like the
19th
century right one can't kind of
formalize this idea of being you know
the professor of philosophy who also
writes the main books of philosophy
a lot of like the major figures before
that never went to school uh or at least
didn't train in the discipline
specifically
a lot of them were trained by the church
in seminaries so
i mean it's certainly not like it's not
impossible to do right i agree with you
100
and i should say like i'm a huge fan of
the promulgation of
the demo or sorry the democratization of
ideas that we see
in this new era right what i just get
concerned about sometimes and i think
victor shares this worry is that
too much of that will lead to falling
standards
uh and people not recognizing that no
you know there's
good ideas and they're bad ideas and one
way you take bad ideas you turn them
into good ideas
is sometimes getting feedback that you
don't necessarily want to hear from
somebody who
just might happen to know a little bit
more than you do about the subject
matter
like there's no shame in that either
like when i [ __ ] like i always tell
my students like
i teach uh legal theory right now my
first legal theory
paper i got a d on it because i
wrote a whack load of stuff about
aristotle and can't that made no
[ __ ] goddamn sense and the prof was
just like look this doesn't make any
sense
you need to focus in on your ideas you
need to like choose a topic and a theme
and go with it
and i didn't like to hear that but it
was good advice you know what i mean
and i've got my ass kicked a few more
times through my undergraduate degree
all the way up through my phd
and eventually you start to develop a
bigger thicker skin to it and you learn
some things
right yeah it's still your process when
you're in academia you're always going
to be getting feedback that it's harsh
that's just that's the nature of it
that's one another thing that i would
say like
if you're somebody who has a hard time
taking critical feedback then definitely
don't go to grad school
like definitely do not come like you you
shouldn't be here because it's going to
be
that's the whole the value you get is
from like harsh criticism i mean even
not that long ago
i had someone a professor look at my
dissertation proposal and he was just
like i don't see why this matters like i
don't understand the
i mean this [ __ ] happens that was a fun
one it's just like i don't see why
you're studying is important that's
always fun yeah exactly
whatever if you can't take constructive
criticism you're not going to succeed in
any [ __ ]
any job anywhere if you're a waiter you
can't take criticism like i think you're
going to get fired pretty quickly
i remember that formative moment also
bringing in a draft of a
proposal i can't even remember if it was
for the dissertation or whatever but
the you see the the fall the face of
your supervisor looking at you
his eyebrows are kind of close together
and goes sorry
but you really don't know what you're
talking about it was a
it was a formative moment well but i
think there's a certain kind of
personality and this goes back to like
the five types that i was talking about
in grad school that gravitates towards
it where
they associate it with a kind of
expressivist ethic where it's like oh
i'm going to go explore ideas that are
really meaningful to me and i'm going to
write something that's extremely
personal personal it's going to
tell people who i am and what my
philosophy is
and that's fine i mean there's nothing
wrong with trying to do that in theory
or in principle
but it's also important to recognize
that if you go to grad school you're not
there to write
your [ __ ] blog right you're there to
learn how to construct ideas and present
them properly
which means that if you just write
something about how you feel this way
about something or what your personal
insights happen to be
people are going to judge you for it and
they should because that's the way that
you'll improve and refine
the ideas that underpin that kind those
kinds of expression and those kind of
sentiments
i mean i'm tempted to bring in the idea
that i hear a lot from people
about not going to grad school why you
shouldn't go to grad school maybe even
why you shouldn't even get an
undergraduate degree or go to university
is because they're going to say that so
many of these successful people
in society don't have degrees or they
dropped out of university
or they didn't complete this or that or
whatever they're going to point at like
directors
and actors suckers leaders and all kinds
of people
like that and say like what's the point
of going to grad school if you can if
you
have a good idea you know chase it drop
out if you need to
and go after it and like school is just
an extension of
grad schools just an extension of
undergrad which is an extension of high
school
and just drop out when you get something
better
i think that's more possible in some
fields than others though in terms of
falling standards though that's
happening
anyway and we could blame the big bad
words
the uh neo-liberalization of the
university
um but one thing we can turn to in in
light of that
is that grad students are accepting
anyone
to these studies doesn't mean you're
good or smart
actually they don't even care if you're
smart no matter how smart you think you
are
that propels your career exactly nowhere
unless
you're talking you already have like a
job pretty much
it might that's that's my observation
the smartest people i know often
struggle
very much but so the reason that they
let you in
is because you are cheap labor for the
university
to take care of their undergrad so that
they don't have to hire
tenure-track positions which is why the
tenure track position count
goes down every year because they
offload it onto you
as a grad student and i don't think any
of us would say we even hate teaching
or we didn't get paid what we were worth
or anything like that that's like
the best part one of the best parts is
getting to teach
but you're not rewarded for that nearly
as much as
you know you're exploited from your
labor how much they pull in
on that and then offload it to you and
increasing responsibilities
offloaded to you yeah i agree with all
that i'm going to say
the four reasons why i think you
shouldn't go to grad school just in the
interest of fairness and
some of these are going to be kind of
funny but like some of them have like a
serious core to them
you know uh number one is if you're like
me your liberal your liver will age at
least
twice as much as it needs to right uh
and
that's faster than the rest of your body
yeah a lot faster than it needs to
that's a pretty common experience i know
with a lot of grad students there's joy
in that also
right but just be aware of that right
the second thing uh and this relates to
what pills was talking about
is you absolutely should not go to it if
you're thinking that this is going to be
a meal ticket right like i said you
should try to find a way to monetize it
because that's just sensible
uh but there's no guarantees in life and
there's less so in grad school than many
other things
right the third reason why i think you
shouldn't go to grad school
is because there is a huge amount of
exploitation that goes on
in the academy and this is one of the
things that i think is extremely
frustrating about it right
um for all the kind of accusations
people make about grad school being a
haven a postmodern cultural marxist or
whatever it happens to be
it's an extremely competitive neoliberal
environment where there's an
extraordinarily rigid hierarchy uh with
the people at the bottom who get very
little and the people at the top who
almost always get a great deal and
that's
after you graduate then you try to get a
post doc
and then you just do someone's [ __ ]
work for them actually i shouldn't
i shouldn't use that term what do you
call it when you have you just
do the work that they don't want to do
grunt work okay yeah
uh and the last thing and this is
associated with it and it's something
that
i think all of us find frustrating right
is because academia is an extremely
competitive
uh neoliberal environment maybe it's
always been this way i don't want to
just blame it on economics
you're going to mean an awful lot of
pretentious douchebags there
just [ __ ] swarms of them right uh
they'll be around you like flies
they're gonna always sit there and ask
how many publications you have where you
publish
where you're getting in postdoc even in
casual conversation and you just know
that they're registering in their mind
whether how they compare to you it's a
really unpleasant thing
and you have to be prepared to have a
thick skin in that kind of environment
like victor was saying
because people are going to judge you
constantly right and it's not a really
can i also just add to that too that
when it comes to like pretentious
douchebags like i think one thing that
i've found useful is
you kind of realize like when you talk
to grad students that actually most grad
students especially even the ones who
are who come off as a little bit
pretentious
are incredibly insecure yeah grad
students are
so [ __ ] insecure it's crazy like if
you
if you know that going in like you can
just feel that you just remember that
because
everyone thinks everyone else it's kind
of like the lacanian like the the
the oh i guess we lost air but it's kind
of like the lacanian audience it's like
we imagine that everyone else like knows
the subject's supposed to know i think
is the thing that everyone else knows
and everyone else is like
gets it but the thing is everyone thinks
that it's a big
like reciprocal it's like a
self-reinforcing cycle of insecurity and
self-loathing
so like if you realize that's what's
going on you can feel a lot better like
we've all hung out with that guy at the
bar who
at the start of the night will be a
perfectly normal good guy to talk to
starting around 9 30 he's gonna be
talking about how his genius how he's
revolutionizing everything
how you don't know to lose as well as he
does so shut the [ __ ] up
but then circa one o'clock it's gonna
come full circle and he's gonna sit
there and be like
i'm nothing i'm a failure you know i
can't do anything
and it's all part and parcel of the same
cycle right like the
insecurity feeds into the ego which
feeds back into the insecurity because
you don't think you're good enough
and everybody feels that way to a
certain extent what i was just getting
at is some people have that syndrome
to the um oh yeah you know i was just
gonna i was just gonna say that like
like it's just if you notice that cycle
going on like you can kind of like get
out of it because if you just realize
that everyone around you like
is is thinking the same way and if not
they're probably like more insecure like
you can you can often feel better but
yeah like definitely
it does feel like there's there's a
there's a feeling like everyone around
you knows so much but really everyone
just everyone else is feeling that too
like everyone else thinks that everyone
else knows better than them and it's
just like that's just how it feels but
and the reality is within two or three
years anybody who's studying something
like seriously will know vastly more
about it than you will like everybody
will usually start off from a place of
relative equivalence
so there might be somebody who just
knows generally more about everything in
the discipline than you will
but like three years down the line if
you've done nothing but study rawls or
duluth or whatever the [ __ ] it happens
to be
you're gonna know more about that
subject matter than pretty much anybody
else will because you've committed to it
and
i gotta stress as well that success has
nothing to do with intelligence and i
hear people kind of
bring this up the the people that you're
talking about
they they think i have the best
interpretation of this this person's
wrong this person is wrong this
is wrong and they're usually the ones
who are they
they drop out because they're like why
does no one here recognize my brilliance
school is not for me yeah that is
definitely a character i don't know if
it fits into your snob character but
they're the same
that knows or thinks they're that
intelligent even if they are
that has no bearing on your success as
an academic
oh yeah absolutely i mean i think going
into grad school and i
think we're thinking of the same person
pills i i i tell this to people
uh to to undergrads who are thinking
about applying to grad school that uh
you know you you can't you you have to
go in
no like you can't just go into it being
like well i'm getting a's and a pluses
on everything so that means i should get
a phd like that's just like the wrong
approach
like yeah so there are really smart
people who go in who are really good at
writing papers and
are really good but yeah like doing a
phd and like trying to
like take a stab at academia there's a
whole game that goes on that you have to
be good at and i think that's kind of
what pills is getting at
when he says that it's not the smartest
people who do all right
now i will like slightly push back on
him and just saying that intelligence
does have something to do with it
because i don't think
like i don't know maybe maybe you're
going to challenge me on this but
i don't i've never come across someone
who ends up being successful who i
thought was stupid like i think
but you're right that like the really
like intelligent minds who blew me away
maybe like they maybe weren't the ones
who end up being successful because
they're so caught up
in their own lofty ideas but they're
terrible at the game of action yeah you
have to
you have to be a game a gamer a
strategic game player
to do the right things to get ahead
that's
getting noticed first of all doing your
work
meeting the right people the networking
thing none of this
like i want to kind of purge people's
what i think are their fantasies about
academia because it's nothing like what
you think if you think the smartest
person
is the one with the credentials because
that's just not the case
and the other thing i wanted to bring up
is in terms of hierarchy
you work with people that got tenure in
like 1970
just total senile
geriatric idiots that are still there i
like those i like those people
you have to be like obsequious it's just
ass kissing otherwise to get to get
ahead
with some of those okay i i t aid for a
guy like
big name published published books name
and we had a lecture on marx it's like a
fourth year
fourth year class lecture on mark's day
and
he talked about the soviet union the
entire time
we had to do a reading from like mark's
capital volume one
and we talked about the soviet union the
entire time
people complained the the students were
complaining about it the other tas
were complaining about it and nothing
ever can happen to these people
despite what they do like sexism racism
you name it they can do whatever they
[ __ ] want
80 years old terrible reviews he's gonna
be there until he's dead
wait i do think that maybe there's an
argument for mandatory retirement at a
certain age maybe like 75 or something
because like
sure there's a couple professors but for
the most part i gotta say i'm more with
matt that like
usually i find the old-timey academics
to be pretty delightful and fun at least
maybe i've just got lucky and had good
ones
you go and get a beer with them and like
they'll tell you like all the [ __ ] about
like some of your heroes
like i went out with the guys like yeah
i [ __ ] went for got a drink with
buckingham like darada you know what
he was a [ __ ] prick and you know like
blah blah blah blah and then they'll
explain wait is that a real story
was dared a prick i've never heard that
that the guy
told me this was like he's flamboyant
and thinks a lot of himself all that
stuff to be fair he was like
anti-deridian so it might have been
biased right but
what i'm saying is like they're like
like elder older people anywhere they
have interesting stories sometimes
every now and then they go on and on and
on but like since you tend to be
interested in the same things a lot of
times that they ramble it's about stuff
that you're
kind of at least somewhat invested in
yeah for sure i mean i i definitely ta
for an old-timey professor who actually
did his phd at u of t and he got there
right i think for like the last year
when alan bloom was still at u of t
and uh he told me he was just like oh my
god what an arrogant prick that guy was
like
i'm shocked to hear that i really am i'd
just like to highlight
the fact that if you're in an
undergraduate degree
and you'll you will never be able to
talk to your professors
like they'll be in they'll run in
they'll lecture and then the secret
service will come and escort them and
they'll chop they'll
fly away in a chopper like you'll never
get to [ __ ] see them but in
graduate degree where there are far less
people
you get a lot more face time with
professors you have a lot more access to
your department and people in it
right you don't have to you're not
sitting in a room
and you're just a number with like 300
other people
around you that was one of the things
that i enjoyed about
grad school i think was that the access
to the professors that you have was on a
completely different level
so if you're interested in your field
and you want to go on to do graduate
studies
like it's a great thing because you get
to finally talk to these people and yes
you're a little bit older
like as a professor i might be a little
hesitant
i mean i'm not a professor but if i were
i might be a little hesitant to go out
with like a
19 year old undergraduate or a 20 even a
21 year old
but like the grads are usually in their
later 20s they're a little more mature
and so you end up going out for drinks
with them going out for drinks with your
professor is not something that tends to
happen in an undergraduate degree
yeah that's a nice thing yeah the access
the exclusivity the socializing yeah you
get to
and and it weeds out like you hear in
your undergraduate you know like those
those fuck-up kids in high school are at
the back of the room and they don't give
a [ __ ] and they holler at you and
they're bullies and [ __ ] they're not
there
and then in grad school even the less
motivated people aren't there it's just
people who
love what they're doing and it's
professors who actually want to engage
with you
so that's that can be nice and who will
actually try to help you
right i mean i was just a number to
[ __ ] 90
of like my undergrad professors it was
really only like some of the ones in
like the
get upper year capstone courses yeah
yeah exactly but like
by the time you get to grad school like
i have pros that i still keep in touch
with nowadays and
they've been really helpful to me right
like they'll write letters of reference
if there's a job that's coming up
they'll send me some links to it
like if there's some project that
working on every now and then they'll be
like hey you want to write something
like this
there's kind of a collaborative thing to
it and there's a lot of advantages to
that that you couldn't really get unless
you were
in that environment you know what i mean
uh and it's a professional
environment which is why you see these
things emerging can i also add in
like two more types of people who
shouldn't go to grad school i have like
two which
i may have kind of mentioned a version
of a long time ago but uh
so like there's the one who comes in uh
who just likes the idea of getting a phd
right i think we've all come across
those people who didn't know what they
were who didn't like have a good reason
for being there other than the fact that
they always did well in classes so
they're like well i guess i should get a
phd
so definitely that's a bad reason i
think that one might be me
uh that one might be more common though
in like non-theater non-theory like i
notice it with some political science
people i know that
they're just like well i was always
doing well so i guess i'll do a phd and
they kind of like the way it sounds in
their ears they're like doing a phd
that sounds cool yeah i want to add just
to that because it's very true like
one thing that you can get that is good
about doing a phd is
if you're not doing anything else with
your life it will silence like all the
naysayers in your family because
at least because like all your uncles
all the people are making more money
than you
will probably at least be like not
intimidated but like somewhat
respectful of the fact that you're doing
a graduate degree so it doesn't matter
that you're making like twenty thousand
dollars and living in a basement
specifically yeah they'll be like oh wow
he's doing his phd he must be doing
something with his life what's the other
type victor
the other type which i've mentioned
before is kind of like the academic
romantic i suppose it's like the one who
comes in and they're like oh i'm going
to change this field i
have the new i'm gonna have the new
theory that's gonna like
i found this new thing in descartes that
no one's ever noticed and everyone's
gonna respect me and i'm gonna write the
most important works
right like i think actually to add to a
point i was making earlier that pills
like touched on the fact that the ones
who end up succeeding usually aren't the
smartest
it's because i think the smartest ones
also often
not always but often are plagued by a
kind of perfectionism that they're like
i'm only going to submit something if
it's perfect i'm only going to submit
something if i think it's
whereas the ones who end up succeeding
are much better at being pragmatists and
being like
yeah i know this argument has flaws but
like it's cool i'm going to send it to
this journal i'm going to send it to
this journal and see what happens i'll
just send it they're just sending
sending sending right and like
that's the kind of the approach you have
to have you have to be a pragmatist
whereas
perfectionists are the type who is like
i'm going to do important work that's
going to change the field
right they're never satisfied they're
too scared to send anything because they
they want it to be like the perfect
groundbreaking thing so if you have that
personality type don't do it i'm not
sure if
that's true though i mean i i definitely
know those people that are like i'm i'm
gonna change i'm gonna change
shelling studies i'm gonna change we are
talking about the same person
i [ __ ] fells i knew it i knew we were
talking about this
i am gonna i'm gonna change hegel
studies
with this thesis that i have and even if
they publish that i mean
a the likelihood is that it's not as
good as they think it is
and b even if it is that good people
don't read stuff
my dissertation committee did not read
my entire dissertation and i could tell
by the questions that they asked me
where i could defer like okay
well i wrote about this in chapter four
but i could tell no
they read chapters one and two never
even finished it
so if you're expecting people to take
you seriously because you take you
seriously
not gonna happen even if you write the
best thing ever does not matter you're
not gonna change a field
even if you have the best idea i do
agree with you that a lot of people do
have this kind of perfectionist streak
which makes it difficult for them to
actually be
productive right uh but i do think that
actually this
indicates more than just a personality
type i think it's been a bit of a shift
in the way the academic environment has
moved towards the neoliberal model
right because if you think about the way
that academia used to be
actually this is related to the kind of
perfect anecdote it used to make right
uh there used to be this sense that
you graduate you get tenure you'd have a
secure job and
therefore you'd have the time and the
resources to sit there and really work
on something for a long period of time
and there wouldn't be intense pressure
put upon you to produce as long as what
you did
down the line was good enough uh and the
example i usually give is something like
rawls theory of justice right went to an
ivy league school
he basically had 15 years where all he
did was publish a few papers then work
on this book it was published it was
clearly
thought through really well and became a
hit
right nobody no institution in the world
i can think of with the exception of a
handful of ivy league schools
would say don't publish anything for 15
years just work until you get the ideas
right
you know i mean take your time they'd
sit there and be like are you [ __ ]
crazy
like you've got to publish like minimum
two papers a year
and you should be working on a book and
you should be going to a conference
and you should also be sitting there and
thinking about getting like your public
persona out there
now to like attract the kids these days
by doing things like this
right prestigious funding grant yeah so
there's here's the achievement
society aspect of it that we've already
discussed yeah can i read
what is philosophy he writes on this
he's talking about all the rivals that
philosophy
true philosophy the creators of concepts
have had
um sociology was the first rival to
philosophy in saying that they create
concepts
but for him i think he wrote this in uh
92
93 or somewhere around there and he says
finally the most shameful moment
of rivals to philosophy came when
computer science
marketing design and advertising all the
disciplines of communication
seized hold of the word concept and said
this
is our concern we are the creative ones
we are the ideas men
we are the friends of the concept we put
it in our computers
information and creativity concept and
enterprise there is already an abundant
bibliography so so much like matt just
said
so much of this being an academic
is actually the marketing aspect it's
not about the
ideas or creating concepts in in
delizi's sense
and i don't even want to get into a
debate over whether or not delis is
right about that
but so much of what we're saying is that
if you are an ideas person
if you love ideas and this is what you
know you kind of get off on
university is not necessarily about that
it might be one of the few places where
you can even get a glimpse of that
but it's certainly not all about that
and success
in university is not based on whether or
not you're a good thinker
a lot of the time if you're a poor
thinker you're going to fail immediately
but even if you're a good thinker it
doesn't mean you'll succeed
definitely agree with that but we
fetishized genius
in this society of ours and we love
stories about
metaphysical clubs and yale groups and
all kinds of cambridge apostles super
super successful
brilliant people who came up with some
groundbreaking theory and
overturned the field dairy does paper in
1968 or whenever it was was
groundbreaking and established a new
field we lost or the toronto school of
communications theory
walter ong marshall mcluhan harold innis
but this is what i mean part of that's
an environment that's disappearing right
now
even though the kind of idealized image
of it like eric was saying hasn't gone
away
like think about wickenstein right rick
stein wrote one 80-page book
uh published one academic article and
then came back to cambridge and they're
like yeah you can stay around for as
long as you want just you know
teach a class every now and then and
when you think you have a good enough
idea for a new book we'll publish it
then
never did anything and all his other
stuff was published posthumously right
but it's all brilliant because he had a
certain amount of time to sit down
reflect talk to students prepare things
and then put them out when they're ready
right i'm not sure if you feel the same
way vic or eric but like
if i were to go to my [ __ ] department
and be like i'm not planning on
publishing anything for 20 years
uh i'm just going to sit down and really
think about my ideas
and then when i'm ready i'm going to
present them to the world they would sit
there and be like well here's the door
right you know just please you know
don't [ __ ] bump into anybody on the
way out right no no you have to you have
to be doing right now like and it's true
i mean right now to be a productive
academic you have to be
doing these mildly and i'll put it you
know very critically to please pills
over here
that like you know you can do these mild
like everyone has to do these mildly
like circle jerky journal articles where
they you know
will say okay here's what the literature
is saying right now
here's what this other person's saying
now i've identified an inconsistency or
a gap between what these two voices are
or
there's a gap here because they didn't
notice this little interpretation in
rawls as justice's fairness where
there's an inconsistency with like
political liberalism
or like some little [ __ ] small like
you know on the head of a pin needle
thing and it's like you have to always
be producing and then or you would talk
about what the contemporary literature
is doing and how
they're not talking they're not paying
attention to this one little detail
and like yeah you're expected to publish
at least two of those a year or
something once you're
but that's that's progress that's how
that's how academic
works by little tiny steps and little
niggling little pedantic little points
like that that's how
like not everyone who comes along just
flips the freaking table
it's not it's not like from galileo to
derrida
it's it's all the stuff that happens in
between no for sure the important
like reading and writing and scholarship
is boring
you're you're basically like a wizard in
the basement of a library
like that image is still pretty accurate
you're not you're not
doing some grand thing you're just
you're
working out little tiny logical
inconsistencies
or you're looking at contradictions or
you're looking at a little i actually
part of that is also the humanities
trying to imitate the success of the
sciences and saying
this is a rigorous logical discipline
and it's advancing
forward which i i you know it's
impossible to make sciences looks like
that too like if there's a mistake
yeah in somebody's formula in somebody's
biological recipe for some kind of
whatever it like if there's a little
tiny mistake in that that could have
huge ramifications and we don't think
about it it's imp
oh it's not as important in the
humanities because we deal with ideas we
don't deal with
formulas or chemistry or physics so it's
not as important if we get a little bit
wrong but it is it should be
like what's the difference between an
idea and a thing
i don't think it is as different in the
stem fields as we sometimes make it out
to be like
my brother-in-law and he was actually my
brother-in-law now i can say that
uh it's doing his degree in particle
physics right he's almost done his phd
really smart guy i sometimes ask him
kind of just like
what's your work a day like and it's
exactly the same thing he's like
people sometimes think that i'm sitting
there imagining what the universe is
like or solving these brand cosmological
problems when really it's just like okay
there's some problem in dr so-and-so's
calculations and your job is to point
that out
and write a paper correcting it so that
way we contribute to our understanding
of this branch of particle theory in
this journal
and maybe you'll get tenure afterwards
right yeah i mean slow incremental
progress
yeah and i agree with like victor's
characterization sometimes that seems
really boring and
pedantic right but i also think that
eric's right that there's something to
be said about that kind of
slow careful scholarship i mean it's
tedious but it makes a contribution
right we shouldn't undervalue it
no i totally agree and i was kind of
framing it negatively just to please
pills over here
this gets to my the big point that i
have
from the start had against academics and
that's that
they're publicly funded
and they don't do anything for the
public because if you're niggling
if you're niggling over these tiny
little issues in order that you can
advance your career
by trying to solve a logical
contradiction
in someone who you know's paper that
they put out
and then we get these like tiny minute
disagreements
then i'm like why are you why are you
being paid for this um
by public funds by taxpayer money which
they often are
if we can do one last transition um i'm
gonna
compel you if i may compel you to
imagine
[ __ ] you what is the future of
this kind of research and how much does
what we're talking about technological
disruption
um there's a lot of theory academic
podcasts in in politics in like ours
for example um trying to be that
public-facing
thing there's a lot of discords to join
online reading groups to join
what part of the university and
it's a kind of expensive in a lot of
cases funding model
how do you see this being disrupted how
do you see what you're doing
like doing a podcast like this for
example um how does that
fit into a new ecosystem where in a lot
of cases
grad school is just unaffordable not an
option
even if you were to get funding
so i can start and i can say that i
think it's a good thing
i feel good about broadening the
educational ecosystem as much as i've
been saying they're irreplaceable things
about grad school and i still strongly
believe that i think that
opening up this platform opening up like
an educational ecosystem to broaden
people who are you know theory curious
or have an aptitude for theory
that's all great stuff and like i thank
our listeners for being interested and
and i hope we're providing something of
value to them they're getting you know a
glimpse of some of the enjoyments that
we have we the appreciation that we have
for theory
but but i will also say like the other
the flip side of is it is
you know already i think there's
probably too many people uh in academic
theory like there's too many people
getting phds probably so to some extent
like
i i don't know i i feel conflicted about
this point because a part of me
feels like elitist about it in a certain
sense and another part of me feels like
egalitarian and i feel like maybe the
broadening of this ecosystem is a way to
reconcile
my kind of elitism with my greater
egalitarian values when it comes to
academic and theory
because to some extent like maybe with
this broadening ecosystem
more people who are theory curious who
like theory but really shouldn't be
doing a phd because it's not for
everyone
this is a nice avenue for those people
uh to do to do theory
in a way that it makes sense fits into
their life they wouldn't actually
necessarily like grad school if they
tried to do it because
they don't want to do the game that
we've been talking about right and it's
like good those people shouldn't be
doing a phd
uh so in some ways like it's good
because this but at this
on the flip side of that there's like an
elitist part of that because it's like i
don't want those people
but the other part is like the people
who are theory curious
should have a place that's quality that
can let them exercise that theory muscle
so to some extent i think this
broadening ecosystem is a way of
reconciling those things and that's kind
of the hope in a way for me
just put that makes theory sound very
sexual i like it
theory curious very curious i'm a little
i'm a little aroused
by that kind of language actually
that's what i thought yeah i'm gonna put
it in a slightly different way because i
agree with everything you said so just
to
kind of build on that i think that one
of the things that we've seen
in the last couple years with the
emergence of all these new media is the
fact that
contra like the kind of conceit of plato
and a lot of the other kind of
intellectual leaders out there
a lot of people are actually really
interested in the world of ideas for its
own sake
right another people have pointed this
out and there's a clear market for that
and i think that people should cater to
that and i think it's actually providing
a useful function
beyond just giving people something to
do with their day and think about
because it can hopefully elevate the
quality of conversation and i imagine
that academics
have a role to play there but i think
that two things need to happen
on both sides right i think that
academics need to be better at
presenting their work to the public
because for all the reasons we talked
about most of the time we're not
right where the people are going to mate
write the little articles about
pedantic issues that are of interest to
scholars but of no interest to everyone
else
right and that's fine there's a place to
that but it's not really all that
interesting uh to people who kind of
want
big picture stuff and we can do that
better right
on the flip side though i think that
sometimes the
downside to going too far to try to
becoming to become a public intellectual
or to make these ideas public
is that standards get lost right and
people think well these ideas are just
you know in the public forum right now
everybody can make use of them however
it is that they want i can use
rawls or marks to justify this or
whatever and i don't think that's good
i think that we need to try to make sure
that we
keep our rigorous set of standards when
it comes to how these ideas are applied
because that's what makes them useful
right if all you're going to do
is just invoke rawls or marks or
whatever to make any
hyperpartisan point that you're going to
make anyway then what's the [ __ ]
point in learning about these things
right you should be using them to try to
think better about things
not just think more eruditely
in terms of doing it for your own sake i
think that's
if you can do it for its own sake and
that's what you want
then don't go to grad school do that and
i got a shout out to some of our
patrons i don't want to say their names
because it's a public episode but
like talking in the discord and he's
like well i read these
four books in the last month and i'm
like holy crap
for fun or for you know
independent intellectual growth
that to me is extremely impressive we do
have a lot of really really smart people
in the discord i totally agree i should
be engaging with it more sorry that i'm
not
i think that's uh extremely impressive
and if yeah
i would i would definitely recommend
that route especially
two to not end grad school with 40 000
student debt
uh eric do you got a a response to the
topic at hand yeah those those those one
yeah join our discord because those
people really they don't need us they're
they're they're in they're so smart they
they got it going like we we're just the
ones who maybe
spent the time to under like get the lay
of the land and then make the
recommendations but they do the work
they don't they don't actually need us
i think that's a huge one of the huge
things that you can't replace by having
not gone to school
is we sort of know where to look when
you need a certain idea
and that's probably from doing
comprehensive exams where you have to
read like 125 books
you kind of know the area what to look
at first
where to find the references and that's
one thing that you can't just get on
your own
that's one thing that a comprehensive
exam list
forces you to do but anyway sorry i
interrupted you since my undergraduate
i've
i've always been someone who's i'm
down for a liberal arts education i am
so down for it it is
so important today that people be
educated in
a broad range of topics including
history literature
politics philosophy sociology and learn
your grammar and learn your logic and
learn some basic mathematics i'm so down
for all of that stuff
and what worries me today is
again the sort of university that
reflects society and society is
functionally differentiated into
very specific and specialized roles
and i don't like the way that the
university
pivots towards those areas because those
are the most lucrative areas right
our school does not build new buildings
because they think that it's going to
attract new scholars to new fields they
build buildings because they get big
donations from
big pharma big oil big chemical
companies whatever
they can get the donations they can
fundraise all
universities now are funded through
foundations
which launders monies through a private
sphere into a public
institution and it's not good i don't
like it
i've always been down for a liberal arts
education
i i was first interested in the
renaissance
and being a renaissance man or woman and
that's awesome
and i think that led into the broad
liberates
style and now we specialize
so that's something i don't like that
the university is going towards and i
think
specialization if you have a job at the
end of it go for it
if not don't do it go go to english
literature go to politics go to
well literature of any language complete
go to philosophy
if you if you don't know if you don't
have a job at the end but you're
someone who's inclined to learn then go
for a
humanities degree go for a liberal arts
degree and take it all the way to the
end of the grad studies
but in another sense like there's two
ways to look at this stuff right from
our personal experience
we enjoyed grad school and we got a lot
out of it but from like a broader social
perspective you got to look at
what sort of function is it serving as a
cultural institution
and where is it going and that
i'm not super happy with we have a big
bloated administration
and we have unions that are just
belligerent and with the best of
intentions but maybe not the best of
effects in the real world
those sorts of things we should oppose
and you should write to your local
congress member or whatever
and tell them tell them tell them that i
said this tell them i
tell them i sent you and that
that's that's a radical proposal though
yeah really like get
out on the streets and put that letter
in the mailbox yeah yeah
and tell them that education should be
free
and tell them eric sent you tell them
eric sent you and tell them that
liberal arts education should be a
requirement for the first
three or four years of your education at
least because you should not be asked
to define what the rest of your life is
going to be
when you're a 19 year old person because
when you're 19 or 18 i'm sorry to our
younger listeners
you don't know anything you don't know
anything about the world but more
importantly you don't know anything
about yourself yet
absolutely you still have growing to do
and deciding
like i'm gonna go into the sciences and
be a chemist at 19 years old
like okay fine you saw breaking bad and
that was pretty [ __ ] cool but that's
probably not what you're going to want
to do
in your mid goddamn 20s so don't do it
go into the liberal arts and then change
into something if you like it
here's me sitting here i wish i did a
mathematics degree
i wish i went into physics i wish i knew
more about quantum physics
well i'm learning that [ __ ] stuff now
and i think if i went back and i changed
my life and did that when i was 19
i'd be a miserable prick right now or
more of a miserable prick than i already
am anyway
so yeah i i think i think grad school
is i mean i would say i would say it's a
buy
it's something you should do yeah but do
for the right reasons don't do it
because
there's a job at the end don't do it
because your parents pressured you into
it do it because it's something you want
to [ __ ] do yeah
and be aware of what it means and yeah
you'll you'll go in you'll you'll end up
with an
enriched soul but empty pockets
right all right well why don't you want
to do a round of like quick advice
we've given a lot of advice but but i
guess if you have more specific
okay closing advice well i i was told
this i can't remember who by but it was
exactly right and it is
do not go to grad school
if you can see yourself happy doing
anything different
if it's the only thing you can do if you
need it there is a need i
had i have that need i need to learn i
always need to be presented with new
ideas
but if you don't need it then don't do
it because it's not worth it
if you want a life if you want to own
real estate at some point in your life
if you want to have a family those are
like huge considerations if those things
are going to
be what make you happy don't go to grad
school
if you need grad school to make you
happy probably all of us to some degree
are on that spectrum and then you're not
gonna listen to me anyway
and if you're that person you should go
knowing the risks
keeping your eyes open and i guess my
practical advice
following what what worked for me is
try to have a professional fallback
that you can do when it all goes to [ __ ]
or that you can do
part-time if you can do something
part-time if you can do something where
you can pick your own hours
um for me it was uh front end web
development
i was able to do that to basically
manage my my debt if you can do
something professional
while you're doing your studies that's
an excellent way to
you know keep perspective on the world
and not just fall into one thing
but don't have this be your only plan
if your only plan is to get a job
if you've got family money go for it
that's going to be great for you but
otherwise make sure you have something
to make your life worth living
when you graduate as someone who's
graduated
yeah i mean i i agree with that i
definitely i mean i'm sympathetic that's
good advice in general like i definitely
felt a need although it's funny because
for me my need was maybe
uh kind of operative slightly
differently because
for me it was yeah there was definitely
a need to be engaged with these ideas
but it was also just utter hatred for
cubicles and
offices uh which i had done i mean i
didn't go back to school until i was
like 23 so i i had like a gap where i
was working
uh and trying to do other stuff and i
just hated that [ __ ] so much so
uh so i just like wanted to be somewhere
where i could just do my own thing and
think about the things i wanted to think
about so
yeah i agree yeah i'm gonna take it to
somewhat different route and said that
uh if you want to get through grad
school not necessarily be successful as
an academic but get through grad school
i think there are two dispositions you
need to avoid and these are the two that
i see that kill everybody
man where did you get this list from i'm
really impressed i thought a lot about
it but like
um i spent a lot of time in grad school
but like number one is people who
basically sit there and
they treat grad school it's essentially
their undergrad again where they're just
going to have a good time
all the time and the school and their
program basically just exist
to facilitate them having a good time
right uh the second poll that i've seen
people go to
is the exact opposite which is basically
to be anxious as [ __ ]
uh constantly be in a state of
existential and professional dread
and to think that nothing is going to
ever work out and these two people might
look very different but they're actually
exactly the same
because in my experience both of them
get almost nothing done
right the anxiety person sits there
worrying about everything all days
sleeps until one or two o'clock uh
writes panicked notes on facebook
and doesn't get anything done the guy
who's partying all the time
sleeps in until two o'clock in the
afternoon because he or she is hungover
uh writes drunken ramblings on facebook
then's at the bar at four o'clock and
gets nothing done okay
uh and that's not to say you can't have
a good time in grad school lord knows i
did
um and that also doesn't mean you
shouldn't be in a state of existential
dread at some point because lord knows
that happened to me
a lot that was pretty much like 2015 in
a nutshell like with just one [ __ ]
long panic attack after another
and then trump became president and god
knows it was worse right but you have to
treat it in my mind kind of like a job
right which is that you should wake up
at semi-regular hours
you should commit yourself to trying to
read at least a couple of hours a day
in your field or outside and then try to
at least carve out an
hour maybe two to do some writing every
day on top of your classes in ta
and if you do that then what you're
gonna find is only does your life have a
little bit more structure
but they'll actually start to advance
little by little
right you know the comps list will get
shorter you'll get a few publications
under your belt and you'll feel better
about that
your dissertation will go from being 300
pages to 200 pages to 100 pages
and then you'll get it done and you can
move on with your life right
which is ultimately what you should do
the ideal person who should go to grad
school
is somebody who ultimately wants to
finish grad school and move on with it
i think okay that's the advice i would
give
all right eric you got anything um
what i would add is that if you're
in your undergraduate and you've had a
hell of a time
because undergraduate degrees are very
difficult and you're probably doing five
courses a week and it's probably
hell like you got to keep your foot
on the pedal and then maybe during your
like let's make a distinction here like
grad school is both master's degrees and
phds so
like like for me i had to keep my foot
pretty deep on the pedal through my
masters too
because it was also a one year masters
which is very strange
and but then once you get into your phd
you can actually like
ease your foot a little bit up off the
pedal it's not
as crazy as an undergraduate
mostly because like there are courses
you have to do but a lot of it starts to
come together
and it just feels a little bit easier
you can relax a little bit
in your graduate like i feel like i feel
like i became a little more of a slob in
my graduate degree because i wasn't as
careful
undergrad i was very disciplined i even
like monitored my spending i was like
100 bucks a week that's all i'm going to
spend anything above that is
bad only 100 bucks a week on tobacco no
more yeah
hundred dollars a week on booze max
and then once i got into my grad school
i was like oh four hundred dollars a
week
no no but
oh god this is the advice section
limit yourself to 400 a week on boots
and if you're gonna drink liquor after
beer make sure
that it's clear liquor you don't want to
drink any of that brown stuff
yeah just have a list of quotes in your
pocket and you'll get laid no problem
yeah seriously though you could like phd
is a little bit of like you can ease up
off the pedal a little bit
it's not as crazy as an undergrad at
least in my experience
i don't know about the stem people but
in the humanities
yeah it gets a little easier you meet
people you feel a little more social
i was like a [ __ ] ninja in my
undergraduate i came in i got in
and then when the class was over i was
like poof smoke grenade and i
disappeared
but in my graduate i lingered i i danced
a little bit i i i stuck around so
but that's where you got to turn all
that free time into uh productivity
the achievement the self-achievement
self-commodification
yeah it is important to have fun right i
mean it's like anything else
if you're going to grad school you
should be passionate about what you're
doing and you should enjoy what you're
doing
otherwise like victor said uh you're
kind of spending a lot of time to
for something that's probably not going
to make you a lot of money in the long
run
so try to find some joy in what you're
doing right if hang out with people that
you like
go to the bar and have those
conversations with your professor and
your friends afterwards
don't skip out on them because you'll
regret it and you're just going to think
back about how stressed off you
absolutely because you know it's a long
process and you have the time and the
opportunity to actually
have a lot of those kind of
conversations that you're probably not
going to be able to have
at least at that level of sophistication
and with that group of people who are as
interested
as you are any other time in your life
right so one stat that i didn't bring up
that i think is probably relevant to
bring up
as a as a closing remark is that
one-third
of phd graduates do not get
work ultimately in their field they
ultimately
leave the field so i mean lots of the
times that's probably
for a high-paying job just because you
have a phd
especially if it's in something like
poli-sci or english then
no matter where you go they know that
you know how to write really really well
and how to
edit edit copy maybe but uh yeah if
you're doing it
if you're doing it as a career step
there are much easier
career steps to do but if you're doing
it for the love of the game
then uh yeah who are we to say don't do
it
yeah for sure for sure god and can i
just say all this talk about like you
know the memories of being with people
at the bar i gotta say it's really
making me miss you guys in person you
know i
cannot [ __ ] wait till we can all be
sitting at a bar and cheers in person
and
i agree i'm slapping each other on the
back and having some yucks
you can record this podcast live again
yeah one time i can't wait till that
[ __ ] day man next next january i
missed that i missed
the phenomenological presence of your
bodies
that sounded slightly sexual so even
even while cove is going on though this
is a a bit of a good point because
there's so much
that we didn't know we could do right we
didn't even know we could do this
podcast remotely
when covid started so finding this
finding the
other you know academic podcasts that
are out there other academic youtube
channels
it's an interesting way to learn and i'm
i'm excited to see uh
where disruption goes i don't i don't
think that people should
go to grad school unless it's the only
thing that you can
possibly do but if you are capable of
independent learning and you have an
actual desire to learn this stuff
uh yeah you could you could sign up for
40 patrons for the same price as a
semester in grad school
and patrons if you want us to like grade
your papers you know like if that's an
interesting idea to you guys you know
maybe we can make another tier
i mean i said i'll put this up anyway
but i brought that up as a joke
i know i know it would be funny though
we'll get back to you in
six to eight months there's desire for
it if there's demand if you want to work
on something and have like actual phds
read it and give you feedback i mean
that's
i mean that's one way to make this
somewhat closer but in any case we
should probably wrap up yeah we'll get
back to you in two to three business
years
with some comments oh we'll just add it
to the bottom of the pile of uh
first papers for this semester so yeah
uh anyway
thanks guys uh good discussion i'm
really interested in the feedback so i'm
gonna post this so if you
if this spoke to you didn't speak to you
you think we're full of [ __ ]
in either case uh it's good to hear
maybe you had a different experience of
grad school that was
just overwhelmingly positive uh i don't
know maybe you're in
norway norway sounds like they've got a
pretty good uh
yeah yeah start like an opposition
podcast
against us i can recommend like a name
you can call it the shell pod because
we're chills
don't start an academic podcast because
we don't want any competition in the
space
all right although it's probably going
to be one of your only options by the
time you get to the end of your phd
anyway so on behalf of uh
pills matt victor eric
enrico oh [ __ ] i was looking at eric
when i said victor and i knew something
that was wrong
i knew there was something wrong so
pills eric
victor matt thanks so much for uh
hanging out with us
and uh stay tuned peace guys
[Music]
cheers
you